failed former president Donald Trump
spoke at the NRA convention over the
weekend and it was as insane as you can
imagine but the backdrop can't be
ignored a backdrop where we have mass
shooting after mass shooting after mass
shooting and the NRA
continues to funnel money to those
elected officials who are willing to
insist we should do nothing about guns
the problem is something else it's
anything but guns we're willing to talk
about almost blood money at this point
that these people are taking from the
NRA and Trump shows up and cheerleads
guns and instead says what about trans
and cannabis as explanations for
shootings and the backs the backdrop of
all of this
is more and more mass shootings if you
look just the last few days a mass
shooting yesterday in Biloxi Mississippi
and a whole bunch of them more than five
on Saturday in Kentucky California
Alabama mass shooting after mass
shooting after mass shooting and Donald
Trump speaks to the NRA like they're
anything short of quite frankly I think
we have to call it an evil group at this
point in time I really am careful with
the language evil I mean wow what other
word can we use at this point to
characterize this organization and
Donald Trump shows up says nothing about
we might want to restrict some people's
access to some guns and instead says we
need a panel to look at whether trans
and cannabis cause mass shootings to
convene an independent outside panel
to investigate whether transgender
hormone treatments and ideology increase
the risk of extreme depression
aggression and even violence I think
most of us already know the answer don't
we do we furthermore really you know
that's one of those funny little it's a
throwaway line I think most of us know
the answer you don't know the answer no
one in that room has data to say trans
ideology causes mass shootings but from
that we we should investigate it but
like we kind of know the answer already
we have to look at whether common
psychiatric drugs as well as genetically
engineered cannabis and other narcotics
are causing psychotic breaks a lot of
problems we're having problems that
we've never seen before and people sort
of think they understand why we must
also be much better at detecting warning
signs of evil disturbed young men like
the one who murdered colleagues in
Louisville we cannot rest until we get
to the bottom of all of the sickness
that we're seeing in our country I mean
listen at least he's conceding that most
of these events are carried out by young
men I guess that's something of an
acknowledgment of reality but he also
raises this idea of psychiatric drugs as
causing mass shootings this is usually
these folks who talk about this are more
specific and they'll actually say ssris
this is something that has been explored
and of course the the difficulty with
looking at something like that is first
of all there are so many people that are
on those medications that it can be very
difficult to find causality but also so
you have to be looking at the
possibility if you were to find some
correlation
you have to consider well it's the folks
the characteristics that got them put on
the drugs are what could be responsible
for their actions rather than the drugs
themselves that's also extraordinarily
difficult to study but they don't care
that's not you know if you sit Trump
down and try to explain that to him
you're not going to get any kind of good
faith response Trump then goes on a rant
about
refrigerators and air conditioners being
shoplifted I guess simple when you see
these gangs of hundreds of young
and apartments or Department Store in
San Francisco and Los Angeles and
Chicago
and they run in by the hundreds and
they're running out carrying
refrigerators and carrying air
conditioners and Big Stuff big little
everything fur coats non-ferco
everything
non-fur coats or as we might call them
coats
um caring and again remember what you to
really understand the sick and evil
nature of this you have to understand
the entire context here oh people in San
Francisco they're just shoplifting
fridges the context is
we need the guns we need the guns to
defend ourselves and others and so on
and so forth a crazy speech and even I
mean listen the audience at these things
is pretty cuckoo but even this audience
was sort of lukewarm on the nonsense
that was spilling out of Donald Trump's
mouth another strange moment during
Trump's NRA speech he displayed tweets
displayed tweets which show him ahead of
other Republican presidential candidates
in a two-way poll of
and there was another poll in Florida
where Trump was at 80.
and to Sanctus was at 15. that's a
Florida poll in Texas it's Trump 52
percent to Sanctus understand that Trump
essentially brought a PowerPoint to the
NRA convention
that's what we've got right now it's a
glorified PowerPoint to to gun nuts 20.
uh
uh you know the only way we can lose is
if we go prevent defense do you agree do
you know what that means in football
where they're holding the team to no
score and then they go prevent the last
two minutes and they lose the game we
will never go prevent but you can take
there you go and Trump notably uh very
very familiarized with sports sports
he's a big Sports guy Trump also capping
the completely unhinged deranged and
delusional and dangerous I might add NRA
speech claiming that there is a Marxist
Revolution going on and you might say
like in what country he means here in
the United States
Congress has to step up and stop this
Marxist Revolution and its tracks we
have a Marxist Revolution going on and I
think you're starting to see it I think
you're starting to see it and we have to
stop it fast this is what we must do to
save our country
[Applause]
so anyway uh Mark you know the the
entire Marxist meme from the right it's
quite laughable and to me the funniest
part about it is if you actually say to
them what is Marxism they don't have a
clue they they just don't have any idea
and you anybody who knows what Marxism
only if you had no clue what it was
might you think that there was Marxism
in the United States uh in any kind of
position of even any power influence
whatsoever but of course there are no
marxists in positions of power in the
house or senate or federal government I
mean it's it's crazy so Top Line
the most disturbing thing is that Trump
is still going and speaking to the NRA
like they're a good organization that's
the Top Line
subsequent to that is the content and
the subject matter from Trump's speech
and that's horrifying in and of itself
and they they've gone fully in
on we're not touching guns
mental health I don't know yeah mental
health but we won't fund it let's look
at mental health culture Marxism
transgender cannabis ssris but the guns
certainly not a factor whatsoever
dangerous and it's not going to change
anytime soon
when you're using websites and apps your
device sends out data about you into the
open who you are where you go things you
like that data then gets sold around for
advertising purposes which is why every
time I connect to the internet I use a
VPN to hide my IP address and our
sponsor private internet access is the
most trustworthy VPN on the market it's
the only VPN that has proven multiple
times in court they don't log your
activity private internet access
protects you from the prying eyes of
hackers your internet service provider
tech companies private internet access
is also super fast for streaming and for
downloads you can watch your favorite
streaming platforms as if you're in
another country like the UK to access
cool new content and with just one
account you can protect unlimited
devices all at the same time this is
really a game changer private internet
access is giving my audience is 83
percent off that's 203 a month plus four
months free go to Pia vpn.com Pacman the
link is down below